the jurogan experience because as a
comedian you have to be on social media
i get i mean i i don't know way not to
be
and it's just like impossible like
to i am so [ __ ] ridiculously addicted
to my phone
like the amount of times that i set it
down going like enough with that [ __ ]
and then i'll just sit there and then
five seconds later i'm just picking it
up
and like you know what it is is it's
also like i watch when even when i'm
watching tv
i'll be like oh look at this old movie i
wasn't that guy still alive right now
and i said look and i oh he died what do
you die of
i had you know 82. you know it's not bad
you know just
let's see if someone's talking [ __ ]
about me yeah well let's no let's i
don't do that i go let's see what these
uh
i don't know social media is bad
i mean it's good and it's bad right the
but the bad part is
you can uh get lost in other people's
opinions and want to defend yourself
and then you know people misrepresent
what you said or distort what you said
or take it out of context
and then you're like hey and then you
think well how many people are reading
that and thinking the wrong thing about
me
and oh no it's just i never respond to
it
i don't either i just flip out i would i
do what i call
post and ghost when i make a post i make
a post and then i
put my phone away and i walk out of the
room i leave my phone in other rooms i
thought you were going to say you write
what you want to say and then you delete
it and i'd be like i'd be too nervous
you accidentally
no no hit send i make a post and then i
go away right like i don't look at
what people are saying about the post i
just get the [ __ ] out of there it's just
it it never is a good use of time
there's so many things that i like to do
and that's one thing that saves me
is that i have so many obsessions right
is that i there's so many things i like
to do
but but the phone will get me if i'm not
if
you know what will get me [ __ ]
youtube and
watching nothing it'll be an hour i'll
watch a a video on how they make watches
and then i'll watch uh three or four
pool matches and then i'll watch oh
1970 chevelle oh how'd they make that
you know what i hate though about all of
those
is once you click on one thing then they
just give you 40 of the same thing
yeah it's like they don't it's almost
like they don't want you to progress
is like um like i had like some of uh
like i watched i i think i told this
story last time i was on here like on
netflix i watched all of narcos
yeah and then everything became like
behind the scenes of san quentin and
blah blah blah so
i've been trying to watch these french
movies right
but for some reason it won't because i
think i'm here they keep giving me like
the english-speaking ones it's like
that's not what i'm trying to do here
i'm trying to watch
their [ __ ] like how do i get out of this
kind of keep dragging you back down to
uh well they find what you're interested
i mean the algorithm is pretty simple
it's not simple it's complicated but
it's a simple formula in terms of like
how it applies
whatever you're interested in it's going
to show you whatever you're going to
spend the most time looking at it's
going to show you
whether it's things you hate like
youtube or facebook that accentuates
things that give you the
it turn it's it turns out it's really
just what you're
responding to and spending time on like
ari did an experiment
ari's experiment was he only looked up
puppies on youtube
that's it just puppies and then all
youtube was showing them was puppies
right he was trying to tell people look
this isn't insidious it's not like the
man's trying to keep you angry
it's like you're keeping yourself angry
if you just go and look at puppies all
day
that's all it's going to show you i
don't know
i i feel like if i look at one puppy
video then they give me
a bunch more and it's just like okay
maybe i've moved past puppies at this
point yeah but that's
up to you you yourself you have to
search for things that aren't puppy
related
i know but it's just easier just to
click on what they're giving away
or they're just oh more puppy videos
this is my safe space
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on
spotify watch back catalog jre videos on
spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience